I've been on this bread I think them up
with chandi's right there and they're
like ain't no Seaver breath
anybody here watching this birds like
they know what's going on with me bro
but on schoolboy q swinging a golf club
house right now these are my stitches
[Music]
I'm gonna know we're without to you know
I got a roll nice white tee I just love
dress yeah that's like my whole thing
I'm gonna know wherever done my drill
breath I just always wanted Diamond
teeth I was just my whole thing 26 but
they're like different foot like
different styles you know they're like
pave BBS invisible say like you named I
got em rough you golf with your teeth
yeah all the time but when I'm on like
the range and stuff like [ __ ]
just like old and stuff and like super
white I don't know put them in boom as
soon as I set the Chi down on the first
hole I got it throw my swagger T down
you know tea tea tea this is my first
rolling right here they actually don't
even make these no more factory diamonds
or whatever presidential cuz I was a kid
I always wanted a Rolex like that's like
the first thing you think about when you
get like a nice chick [ __ ] homeowner
watch like so my grandma said a minute a
man if you don't wear a watch whatever
that means but I wanted to have one of
the best watches and I brought this
mostly cute it still looks pretty good I
don't your wrist oh this stuff's just a
big boy right here like this the
Platinum one dog this is we ain't gonna
talk about here this fall like that's
like I can knock somebody teeth out like
that's a whole different ballgame
I gotta have a change this what what
kind of wheat but I don't really wear a
jury like that like I got this for like
a g0 Co real diamonds but it's like the
things that I always wanted to wear when
I'm playing I just got to feel kind of
saucy you know what I mean like when I'm
gonna of course like cuz I'm not that
good at playing golf or I may not have
the best score but I'm always looking
nicer on the court you ain't [ __ ] I lied
I'll tell the job and I think about 40
G's it was under I think I know where
doctor finally people look at goblins go
check all decks breath I'm doing exactly
what you doing every day at home sitting
on your ass
smoking and drinking but I'm outside
with it you know what the hungry I used
to think the same thing like you know
I'm saying I never thought I'd be
playing golf and so I went out here to
realize I'm just taking it with the
homies so yeah I pretty much all you got
the Fonz a week next
[Music]
you can't smoke around our line Coby my
wallet I need a wallet I guess so
and I didn't really come up with 10
things I'm just being honest to people
so I decided to my water than here I
don't go nowhere without my ID so just
essential next don't throw my golf club
dad
well you know you can throw it don't
like like it hey buddy he likes it this
is my pitching wedge man if I have to
say any of my irons my pitching wedge is
my favorite like I would rather be 130
from the pan didn't sixty yards because
I have way more confidence with this
club of my hand and I can't leave home
without it right that's like a celerity
yeah they've all pretty trashed like
most celebrities are too busy you got to
practice like every day you got
something really good Patrick Peterson
mate 21 right I saw usually worth 21 -
but check this up
if you're ever in LA come on let your
boy mate are you golfer you see me come
on your messaging boy
[Music]
Oh telly bad you so talented ready go
see breath this is actually brew life I
need to tease but there's no story
behind and stuff we just really do these
in because I want to do that catch right
there to show y'all card I have you
peasants gonna have these some still
using cords and stuff you complain about
it yeah do you get new ones
yeah like what not these are cool cuz
like when you on the range you got a
final call boat talk you can do a full
swing cord don't get in the way I can't
even go off now without him so I think
you thought that is I put my mouth on
his mouth but your slider but I got bad
eyes and just crazy cuz I smoke a lot of
Bud but I never knew what it was like to
not have asthma since I was a little
baby baby I remember to exact age but I
remember being in the back of an
ambulance and my momma crying like
that's like one of the only things I
remember from being like real small so I
just never leave it out it no you ever
gotten like a long period of time
without smoking it was like since
Missoni smoke and then I went like
straight papers no tobacco and idea
realized though it's easier your lungs
well asthmatic for shorter smoke papers
and honestly but I just love Fox
anything I'm I'm sorry I'm not trying to
live like 2089
I'm like really just like trying to
cakey
[Music]
so my range finder dock is for in
distances outside there so I need like
my god how far it is the slow part you
know because I'm not that good at just
judging off looking but if you can
afford it you're gonna buy a rangefinder
they're pretty expensive but most
golfers on note have a range from the
rather special known or the cheapest one
how many have you gone through using a
lot er yeah this is my third one
these things are um 500 of pop one of
them got beat up by dog you just like
heated up real real bad it mr. lenz up
then I lost mine I didn't
three months later somebody gave it back
to me so now I have to money I mean you
never know who may be out the course I
mean after bed you know somebody made
you talk to Mitch yeah you may be
feeling good I don't know most people we
put herself on the line it just make the
game interesting so we just think
getting to lie to Joe you know I mean
what we still like focus on it playing
off and still like having fun so my boy
June he's the reason I'm even playing
golf he bedded me 10 grand I couldn't
make a birdie in two years and I made
that birdie said you had two favorites
in green and said he had never met me
again he had been everybody on the
course he won't move me
you